Alright, we're going to look at another algorithm that kind
of takes the idea of random restarts one step further.
Instead of just waiting until you hit a local optimum
to, to decide that you're going to randomly restart, there's always
a chance of taking a step in a downward direction
while you're trying to do your hill climbing. And the
algorithm that we're talking about in concretely is called Simulating
Annealing. So the basic idea is that we don't always improve.
Sometimes we actually need to search. We need to take the point
where we are now and wander away from it, with the hope
of finding something even better. And you can think of this as
being related to the notion exploring and exploiting. The hill climbing is what
it's doing is always trying to exploit. It's always trying to climb
its way up the hill as quickly as it can, which can
lead it to getting stuck. Exploring is the idea of visiting more
of the space with the hope that you can actually climb even further.
>> So,
which is better then, exploring or exploiting?
>> Well you have to trade these off really carefully. So, if you're just
exploring, it means you're just randomly wandering
around the space. You're not using any of
the local information to improve yourself. But if you only exploit then you can
get stuck in these local optima. So you need to do a bit of both.
>> So, since I'm always trying to connect
this back to stuff we talked before. If you
exploit all the time that's kind of like
overfitting. That's like believing your data too much and
not taking any chances at all. Does that make
sense or is that too much of a stretch?
>> I doesn't make sense to be me but I'm sure it make sense to you.
>> [LAUGH] It makes sense to me.
>> So you want to think of that as being kind of like overfitting.
>> Well, you know, the fundamental problem of overfitting, right,
is believing your data too much. And, and dealing with just
the coincidences of what you happen to see. And that's
like being very myopic. And exploiting, in this case, only taking
the direction which you go is like believing the data point
where you happen to be. I predict, from this one example, that
I should be headed in this direction, and I don't care about
anything else. And I'm not going to worry about anything else. Well,
that's kind of like believing too much, which is sort of
what overfitting is. Meanwhile search on the other hand, the exploring, is
like believing nothing and taking advantage of nothing. So obviously as you
need to take, as you said, take advantage of the local information.
You need to believe it at least a little bit at least
some of time time or otherwise it's as if you've learned nothing.
>> Alright, well I definitely agree with
you that there's a trade-off there and that
there's a resemblance to overfitting. I don't,
I don't know how deep that resemblance is.
>> Superficial. They're like twin cousins.
>> Twin cousins from another family branch. So the simulated annealing
algorithm that we're talking about is
related to an algorithm called Metropolis-Hastings,
which I always thought sounded really cool. And the whole
idea of it actually gets into metallurgy. So here I drew
a picture of a sword. And we want the sword,
when we're making a sword if we're a blacksmith and we're
making a sword, we want it to be nice and
hard. And the way to make it hard and sharp, and,
and, and well structured, is for all the molecules to
be, be aligned in the same way. So they fit together
very snugly and they kind of lock in. And, so, there is
a bit of an optimization process that has to happen. There is
all these different ways that the molecules can be arranged and we
would like to settle into an arrangement that has the lowest energy. Well,
it turns out that the way blacksmiths have figured out to do
this is they will make the sword and then do repeated hea,
heating and cooling, and that actually show, they can see that that
actually strengthens the blade, and, and
what's really happening at the molecular level
is it's giving the molecules an opportunity to
realign themselves, to find an even better solution to
the problem of how they can all fit into
that space. So, this annealing is, is this idea
of heating and cooling. And we're not really
literally heating and cooling, though of course when we
run the computer it is getting a bit hotter.
We're just simulating the idea of the temperature changing.